Hello, who
are you? Can I
ask you a question? Good morning Good morning What is it
?
No, I
haven't really thought about it, but what do you think about this phenomenon? I do
n't think it's that bad  That's why I
came here to save everyone
Excuse me, who was that accent
?
If you lose your road map in , you'll get lost
Japanese
[music]
yes yes yes yes yes All of these are the devil
's learning methods
No,
but he's a very cute kid with a high head
and flat plate
Think about him  Won't you please
give me the correct knowledge before I learn the wrong pronunciation
?  It's
not suffocating to think that I have to follow so many rules.Of
course there are times like that, but I know this is the
right way to go, so there are a
lot of exceptions and contradictions.